more than 10 000 people have crossed
from Sudan into neighboring Chad the
world food program says that number
could rise to a hundred thousand so
joining us on the phone from Chad's
capital and Jamina is freelance
journalist
um Carol do you have been to the Border
areas where Sydney's refugees started
arriving share with us what you saw and
what you heard
yeah thank you I so people crossing the
border every day more and more people
get their numbers exact number uh it's
increasing but we don't know exactly how
many they are because the ngos are still
counting but according to local sources
there could be already more than 20 000
of them and they are surviving in
Desperate conditions it's the side
region so you have to imagine it's a
very driverless place it's almost Barren
there is no shade no place to take
shelter and Adventures there they rise
above 44 degrees so the the refugees
they are lacking everything basic water
food shelter and they are currently
sleeping in the open air
did they describe specifically what they
were fleeing what the conditions were in
the the regions that they came from are
civilians being directly targeted there
or are they just afraid of being caught
in crossfire what do they tell you
well therefore the first of them we were
arrived in the in the past days to Chad
there were uh fleeing attacks from uh in
their in their Villages and there were
they were also reporting uh lootings and
also one Village that was burned down
but most of the people uh were in the
daffo region the region at the border
with Chad they are uh cooked still
cooked in the in the fightings so for
the moment they they can't move and
that's why humanitarians expect more and
more of them to come in the next day as
soon as the fighting stops did you see
people continue to arrive as you were
there were they arriving continuously
[Music]
so right at the
at which where I was there was a
constant
arrival of uh of refugees
are there concerns about destabilizing
potentially Chad where this is security
situation there is fragile
yes uh absolutely uh and right now in
gemina everyone is talking about that uh
everyone's talking about the fear of
this stabilization coming from Sudan uh
all the most so that you are the same
communities that live that live uh
across the border so uh right now the
Army is deployed at the border to
prevent this uh but we already had some
Sudanese soldiers who crossed each other
and have been designed by charging
forces uh here everyone is remembering
the the rebellions uh which came from
Sudan in the in the 90s but even more
people are talking and remembering the
war in that room which started 20 years
ago and um 300 000 people die because
the ginger with militias they were
fighting at this time there have been
for many integrated into the rsf so dafu
is considered to be a strong vote for
the general enmity and also as a place
where it could it might come back in
case uh his forces were to be defeated
all right Carol Vela thank you for
joining us on the program today let's
bring in Muhammad Bal he's reported
extensively from Sudan uh Mohammed
you're joining us on set normally what
you do part of what you do is obviously
you work your sources and your contacts
on the ground that's just become a lot
harder over the last 24 hours or so
exactly many of the people I tried to
call overnight and this morning who are
not clearly were not receiving able to
receive my calls and that ex that's the
explanation of that is that there is
this internet blackout at times and also
a you know normal communication lines
blackout
more serious than that probably is the
the
um the inability of anyone to go and and
and and and communicate directly with
with the neighbors uh people are holed
up they are trapped in their homes uh
when I was able to communicate with some
of them they were telling me that you
know in certain residential districts
they were forced out of their homes by
the by the uh rsf yes the support forces
because the sport forces now their main
hideouts are the residential areas so
their only means of survival and to
sustain themselves is to go inside homes
and and loot this is according to my
contacts you know and that has added to
the difficulty of of the situation in
residential areas in many in many areas
in cultural so getting reports now of
the rsf actually looting residential
areas which I think is significant cases
I'm talking about some cases individual
cases people I talked to they said they
they forced us out of our homes and they
stayed in the homes is it for looting or
is it for protection they wanted to hide
in the homes but apparently the rsf are
out of supplies it's very clear that not
many supplies are entering cartoon and
they have been for 10 days trapped
inside residential areas so the only way
for them to uh to to find food and drink
is to go inside homes or to loot uh
the commercial buildings and shops and
the residents of cartoon that you were
able to speak to are they trying to
leave the capital of course all of them
they want to find them is they want to
find a way to live but they can't and
also the other crisis that has
compounded this situation is the lack of
fuel across cartoon that could be a in a
way that could be a very
dangerous situation for civilians
because it it leads to power cuts it
leads a lot of services being being cut
but also at the same time it might
explain this this quiet that we see in
cartoon because uh even the items like
something new flagged as something that
we should be monitoring yes the fighting
parties particularly the rsf the support
forces they don't have fuel supplies for
their for their four-wheel drives
anymore most of the time so I mean that
can explain this lack of Mobility for
attacks inside cartoon so that could be
a that could be a a positive situation
but at the same time the other the other
impact of the lack of fuel is on
civilians on services on bakeries on uh
on on banks on internet on communication
lines and the ability even to evacuate
people you were telling me a moment ago
that so when the the three-day ceasefire
uh I hesitate to call it a ceasefire
because they were still fighting during
that period but when the three-day
ceasefire ended overnight the fighting
did not resume full force there is
fighting but it is
we can perhaps describe it as moderate
you were telling me clearly there were
hours and hours after midnight there
were hours of quiet
and people were even inquiring what's
the meaning of this are they extending
this ceasefire unofficially
but there are some explanations to this
I mentioned this this lack of fuel to
move for the vehicles for the Army and
also particularly for the rsf
but also there is a level of exhaustion
10 days of fighting uh there is a there
is a level of exhaustion and there is a
moment of probably thinking about what
has been achieved and what can be
achieved it's very clear
the two sides are unable to to gain a
decisive Victory on either side has won
this so I mean this might be an
opportunity also the other Factor Cyril
is the evacuations have not yet been
completed so there is a lot of
um hesitation on both sides to uh to
kill the foreigners who are being
evacuated and they know that those
foreigners can be caught in the
crossfire if fighting if the exchange of
fire continues during the evacuation
yeah and they both both generals Mr
burhan Mr hametti they both said
um publicly that they would let people
evacuate who wanted to evacuate and
exactly exactly right Mohammed Mohammed
Val thank you so much